[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm Rhett and I'm link this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we're going
grease you up for Thanksgiving oh gosh
like a turkey you know how you rub the
turkey with stuff before you put it in
the thing to then go through the process
so you can then it eat it that's what
we're doing to you ears right and what
do you know about that process I've been
I flip through the channels on a
television I would see people preparing
turkeys and sometimes Internet videos
float around of people preparing turkeys
in new creative ways when you're an
application was that they were greasing
it up yeah you just grease it up and
then it's kind of like a it's kind of
like a pig that you're trying to I know
that would be pork butt that you were
you're trying to you know you're trying
to chase yeah trying to Crowley a turkey
is like a pig
that's greased yeah I could tell you
don't spend a lot of time in the kitchen
unless you're eating we're gonna we're
gonna have based we're gonna based you
we're gonna baste your ears oh gosh all
the mental pictures that you're creating
for people because this has you seen a
turkey baster before this is the week of
they look like some sort of dropper for
a for an ogre of you know what I'm sayin
the truck before it okay that this is
the week to be thankful man we've we've
designated that we've designated it and
we can get it out of our system so the
rest of the year we don't have to be
thankful at all no that's not true is it
this is an opportunity to be especially
thankful the focus on gratitude to focus
on gratitude and so we're happy to do
that we're gonna do that today
we dedicated an entire chapter of the
book of mythicality - what we called
throwback thanks and we're gonna get
into what we didn't do in the book was
when we thank some people we didn't get
into a lot of the backstories or like we
weren't able to fully flesh out why we
were thinking these people we limited it
to a couple of note card sized
thank you notes within our book so we
just thought this would be a fun
opportunity for us to to expound on
those things so we're gonna do that
today we're also gonna hear some of the
throwback things from new mythical
beasts yep
but first you know you're still greased
up from your my birthday party I had a
very late birthday party because we've
been traveling a whole bunch and the
only time that we could get in the venue
that we wanted in the band that we
wanted was this particular day but you
told me that because you know I I had
the advantage of turning there there are
certain disadvantages of being older
than you like what just being the guy
that hits 41st is not that's not
something you want to sign up for it's
scary but the advantage that I have
recently discovered is that now you have
to live up to the party that I threw
myself really that my wife threw for me
right well for months leading up to you
crossing the precipice breaking the seal
on 40 there were there were murmurs
there were discussions of a party it's
all right well if you're gonna have a
big birthday party you should be if it
should be 40 and I was in full support
of a great celebration then I would not
have to foot the bill for but I would
fully engage in enjoying but I did put
it on the company so I mean you throw a
big party man it was like it started
small and I got a little out of hand
well I wouldn't say it started well in
the conversation is that I heard between
you and Jesse about this party and the
ones that I was involved in it was like
well once she decided you were gonna get
a band I don't which came first deciding
to get a band or knowing about the band
and then building a party around the
band because well so over a year ago my
wife said or probably right after I
turned 39 she was like now do you want
to do something substantial for your
40th birthday party because we don't
they do big parties for birthdays it's
just not something that you know Jesse
we're usually back home in North
Carolina for her birthday my birthday
always comes in the middle of a really
really busy time for us October is
always really busy so we just haven't
thrown parties but when she said that I
was like I think I want to have a party
on a boat and I want harbour party the
band to play that was that's all I said
at that time so so you thought about
boat yeah it was a package deal in your
mind I thought it was from the moment we
saw that band which you should tell him
who Harbor party is that that's the
linchpin of this entire experience first
of all a lot of people did a lot of
social media at the party and a lot of
that spread and so there's a lot of
people who who or you know the people
the mythical beast who do a lot of
digging on the internet to find out
things they already know all about this
because there was a lot of smiling chats
and insta stories I mean I've seen
myself singing that freaking song a
million times from a bunch of different
angles because everybody was filming it
but what were we saying
what it was a question you asked me
Harbor party harbor barber party so
harbour party is a band that we saw play
together for the first time at good
times at Davey Wayne's a club a music
club in Hollywood but but now just to
call them a band is almost well I'm
first going to say I've never been to a
music club and watched a band play that
I would like I've seen bands because I
buy a ticket to their concert but I I
mean I don't think I've ever been to a
club period actually I've been to like a
club for like somebody's party who had a
party at a club but but I don't do the
clubbing thing but our friends garen
Rebecca knew about this band because
garze brother was friends with the
really close friends with the lead
singer and they were like you're gonna
love this band you're gonna love this
venue we should all go and hang out and
this venue it looked kind of like a when
you get inside it's low ceilings and a
couple of rooms and it it looks like a
frat house inside like you're literally
in a
but it's a very very cool very very very
cool place and then in the corner also
like a speakeasy when you get you walk
into the lobby great
it looks like just a room a little shop
with like a refrigerator in it
hey you walk through the room or the
refrigerator in division you're in this
music awesome is that
and then without any stage just in the
corner just like you would have a house
party band there's a band plan over
there and it's the band that they wanted
us to see Harbor party and they're
playing Yacht rock which only Yacht rock
which we've learned that not a lot of
people knew well Yacht rock was I'm
surprised because Yacht rock is my
favorite type of music
I mean basically to explain it to you
it's um it's like late seventies early
eighties soul music that is mostly
played by white people I'm just gonna be
you know honest that's like that's what
they call blue-eyed soul look now like a
Michael McDonald yeah Doobie Brothers
Hall & Oates yeah it's like when white
people are getting as funky as they
possibly can right it's like the limit
of white funk within it so and you make
fun of it by saying well night if you
get a rich guy on a yacht this is the
music he listens to because it's kind of
like it's kind of a second rate it's
it's not it'll embarrass it's easy
listening but it's also a little funky
but it's not so funky that you begin to
you're gonna hurt yourself
right you can still like have a fishing
rod and and so I would respect anyone I
would not argue with anyone say yeah but
it's not the real deal if you I mean if
you want to talk about funk you couldn't
talk about James Brown right we're gonna
talk about somebody who actually brings
the fun it's derivative this thing this
is derivative right but it's still
incredible and it's like smoothed out
and for for palatability of people on
yachts I guess I'm right now and and
these guys so everybody in this band and
if Michael McDonald sings a song then
you're gonna bet that that's a yacht
rock song right so okay
for Girton and everybody in the band is
a professional musician in their own
right and usually a part of another band
or like a studio musician so they're
great at their particular instrument
whether it's the voice or the base or
the keyboards or whatever everybody is
just an incredible musician
professionally and then they all come
together really as a side project you
form this band that plays at places like
good times at Davey Wayne's but they
also will do parties and just like I
told everybody at my party when I got up
to give my little birthday boy speech
everyone underestimates it like when you
say this is a great band you're like
okay why are you making such a big deal
out about about this band and then you
see them and experience it in person
you're like well I can't I can't fathom
this but I will say that there was
definitely a little bit of a segregation
between the old people me yes us getting
into our late 30s and then the light
right in the sweet spot of Millennials
that we have working for us yeah and I
you know in it there was there was this
moment where we were up there like
dancing our just dancing our butts off
just like having the greatest time and I
kind of looked back and like saw like a
sea of Millennials and I realized that
we have become our parents or like yes
this is that uncles
this is like when I went to a party like
I would see my parents like get really
excited about 50s music when I was
growing up yeah and I was always like
that song is good it's good stuff but
like it's a little embarrassing when mom
and dad start dancing to like the Four
Seasons you know what I'm saying or
Chuck Berry or something like that and
you know what makes it even sadder for
us we don't have yachts yeah we don't
you know I mean into that if we had a
yacht then you'd be like yeah but I got
a yacht I mean I'm on it
I'm dancing on the yacht well so that
was the idea what the come full-circle
yeah I wanted to have a Yacht rock band
on a yacht then I looked into how much
that cost and very quickly learned that
that was not what I wanted to do I could
have had like a jon boat party that
would have that would have been an
intimate affordable but I wanted to have
you know like
around a hundred people at this thing so
if you want to put a hundred people on a
boat don't sing if it's johnboat that's
gonna sing yeah so we quickly down the
under the sea thing from boat to some to
club which I thought was just a perfect
venue for those guys who had a nice
stage but Jesse planned a lot of a lot
of it was details it was perfect there
wasn't there was the stage and then
there was like a bar behind the you know
behind the stage in it in between in
between the bar in the stage there was
like a little dance floor but not not
too big to wear with that amount of
people it was like everything was full
so it didn't seem like there was like a
big gap where some somebody should have
been but they weren't and here's the one
thing that I was able to do because I
didn't have it on the boat Jesse thought
it would be a great idea to get a
lobster roll food truck she's a genius
that was so good and the cousins Maine
lobster food truck that had two types of
lobster rolls Connecticut style and main
style Connecticut is the warm lobster
with butter on it which is the one that
I get and I got and they had lobster
bisque tater tots it was absolutely
incredible so it's like being on a yacht
that was parked and having somebody who
had caught lobster and made it into
lobster rolls perfectly for you and then
and then she remember the pie hole that
we that we shot an episode of Willett
Piatt yeah we got pies from Willett pile
because I tried a Earl Grey tea pie when
I was in Pasadena at pie hole and I was
like this is the best thing I've ever
eaten and Jesse said I'm gonna have that
at your birthday party so so many things
just came together and of course I did
choose to perform a song with the band
which I was a little intimidated you
know this because I was telling you in
the days leading up there yeah a little
pressure cuz this is it we got it really
good musicians you know these
professionals I got to get up there and
I got a dance and I got to sing so I
decided to sing not any of the songs
that I know that they do so well I
didn't want to ruin any of the songs
that I wasn't gonna any Halla notes I
was gonna sing any Toto I wasn't gonna
sing any Michael Jackson they do Michael
Jackson which is not exactly right but
they throw in some you can't if somebody
starts playing Michael Jackson you're
not gonna stop so I was like I'm not
going to sing
any of the songs that I'll screw up but
it's got to be a song that people will
recognize and I can actually sing so I
sing brandy and first offense
parenthetically you're a fine girl
Stevie and Cassie both thought so when I
talked to Cassie about this shoot I was
like I'm performing a song and she's
like what are you singing I was like
Brandi and then she went and told Stevie
that I was performing a brandy song from
brandy and so then when the band started
playing like the whole night Cassie was
like I don't understand how Rhett's
gonna perform a brandy song and how this
is gonna make sense and then when I
perform brandy by Looking Glass a
one-hit wonder who recently has come
back into you know the public eye
because they're on the guardians of the
galaxy soundtrack but mm-hmm
she was like makes a whole lot more
sense and anyway
you you were tell me worried about it
because tell me your brave ladies days
leading up to it there'd be like a lull
in conversation where we were talking
about work or something else and then
you'd be like I was like dude I think it
would be great if you just kind of like
mumble to your way through it because
that's kind of how he sings like
I was committed to that for a couple of
days but I was worried it was kind of a
risk I was worried that people might not
get you know I took all this time to
memorize the lyrics yeah you did and
then they had just had the lyrics on an
iPad up there so I took I spent hours
hours yeah and then well here's my
experience I'm out there just having the
time of my life man I was happy for you
that you were indeed 40 and you know
what you didn't look that decrepit I
mean you got on stage you performed a
song I was like there's hope for me
right but then I hope started to - a
little bit because one person came up
and asked me something a few minutes
later another person comes up asked me
the same thing mm-hmm
a few minutes later somebody else is
talking to me and then changes the
subject to say the same thing right
everyone was asking me what are you
gonna do for your party I'm like man I
I was thinking about it a little bit but
I didn't realize everybody else was
thinking about it a couple of people
come like complimented me on the party
and then realized that it wasn't my
party
some people associate us so closely that
I got compliments and I was like yeah
it's great Christy said the same I did
not spend a dime on this somebody came
up to her and was like great party so I
don't I I mean my response at time would
be like yeah I know know what I'm gonna
do but you're invited and then by then
I'm like I'm not doing anything and
you're not invited you're just gonna go
on a trip I'm just I I was I was like I
gotta go in a totally different
direction maybe I'll take like what they
call a sabbatical I'll take a 400
sabbatical like 40 minutes on my own I'm
trying to keep it small like I want 40
minutes to myself well I don't know I I
feel like we should figure out a way for
you to I don't want I didn't have any
other band
I feel like hold on but let's think
about this here's what here's an speed
it'll be Brandi speaking of the book
because we have a chapter in the book
called throw a party that doesn't suck
you know and I got to say that that
chapter wasn't necessarily my favorite
chapter of the book you know because I
was like this isn't as I mean we told a
funny story about going to the party at
Red Fu's house which is a really funny
thing but into it was a little more
frivolous if you have to like rank the
chapters from like yeah you know
applicability to your life and then
frivolity is that a word throwing a
party that doesn't suck I would have
said this as a pretty frivolous thing
but having thrown a party that you know
Jesse and I threw everything we could at
this party to make it great and we
talked on the way there though how we
were more concerned about everyone else
enjoying themselves than we were
enjoying it ourselves kind of like you
your wedding yeah but so many people
came up and said they had such a great
time in fact one of our friends came up
and had a few drinks but he said this is
the best night of my life and what a sad
friend having her
heard that from multiple people as
pretty good night it just made me it
made me so happy I was like people had
such a good time it may this has given
me a new perspective on parties and
throwing parties and I feel like it
lived up to the standard that we said in
the book to throw a mythical party and
so I don't feel like you can bow out I
feel like you have to embrace this
challenge and you've got to beat me you
got to throw a better party than me you
got to have live animals you got to have
fire dancers we are gonna get a boat you
can combine you and Chrissy's birthdays
together cuz you guys are gonna be 40 in
like within a month or two yeah so you
got you got that going for you so
financially speaking it's like you're I
get to wait like four years for my wife
to turn 40 before we've got to spend
more money on that you don't you don't
have any daughters though you made that
point like this whole I mean if you have
to pay for a wedding I mean does that
hold true anymore I don't know thanks
for new 2017 I think hope not I think
that that tradition is changing a little
can funnel all of that money in them
into my own party I don't know I don't I
haven't talked anybody's got married
recently but I it's probably more
collaborative than it used to be
I hope so it's probably not just like
the bride's family pays for the whole
thing I don't know you you should
negotiate that you know don't worry
about that that's years away
I hope so about that too I just think we
got to figure out a way to minute you
you got I don't mean him but I got a
kids I've got an idea
I definitely I've got lots of kids like
toddlers there I've got an idea and I
will make it my mission
oh you're together with you to make this
happen I there is one way that we can
that we can do better than harbour party
Lionel Richie did you hear you just
burped because it misses Oh emotion I it
wasn't a burp your soul just tried to
escape and came back okay that noise
came out of like my if I had a trach
that's where that that's where that
noise would have come out of we are
going to make it our mission we have how
many months do we have we've got over $6
for us to figure out how we get Lionel
Richie to play at you and your wife's
40th birthday party but then you've
spoiled the surprise because I would
want it to be a surprise to everybody
well you got a
nobody me but I gotta go public with
this in order to get him on board yeah
yeah yeah but I'd still like Harbor
party to back him up and I would like
him I'm sure he's got a pretty good band
yeah that's all I'm saying and it will
be on a yacht I will help you I will
help you make that a reality
private yeah there will be no hard
feelings at all if you can hovercraft to
play at your birthday party feel like
that's that's really you'll have a
choice at this at this point
mmm you could you want a sabbatical
though if you don't get Lionel I mean I
was definitely thinking I'm just gonna
go on a trip because I get so you know
how nervous I get when people when I'm
in charge of making people happy yeah
but yet understand I felt the same way
and having been through it I've been
feeling so good this week because so
many people have sent emails and texts
just like I had such a good time but but
you makes me have to tell you that
you're cool I don't need that Oh give me
a break I feel like I have more to lose
than the game know if you have Lionel
Richie there okay and if you don't have
Lana Richie we'll get a line Rashmi
impersonate her and I'm gonna keep the
lights low put him at a distance yeah
he's over there stay over there
contractually he does not allow us to
come close to him okay I'll think about
it think about it we're gonna continue
with this but first we are going to just
remind you how committed we are to
beautifying you mm-hmm with our beauty
products mythical beauty products we
unabashedly use the term beauty when we
talk about our mythical pomade works on
anybody's hair we got beard oil or could
beat the hair of defeat with that
mythical pomade anybody's beard and I
have already announced this but I am
still riding the wave super excited
about my all-new lip balm I've been
jealous of links lip balm for the past
year or so you know how I feel about
your party now but I combined two of my
favorite things Wood and berries and
you're gonna be like would would I like
to try that you would like to try it
because it tastes incredible and it's
got this berry flavor which is a black
berry flavor added to the wood and it's
almost like going up to a blackberry
bush without without thorns and just
rubbing your face all over and make
and which I got to say is something that
you want to do but it's much smoother
than that and I I love Bret's lip balm
as the secondary to my own but you can
mitigate your perceived risk by also
buying the peculiarly perfect peanut
butter peppermint lip balm which is
proven to be the softest most supple lip
creator on Amazon and it also reviews
there saying it also has new packaging
to pack so that we look great together
go together they look great together the
mythical dots store is what you get all
that for supporting internet Ament in
the book we talked about hashtag TBT but
how we changed it to be throwback thanks
where it's the phenomenon where you
reflect on milestones in your life and
then realize that people played a role
in that yet you forgot to thank them or
you were thankful but you didn't
articulate it and you know what it's
never too late to go back as we proved
when in our documentary looking for miss
Locklear when we would track down our
first grade teacher who introduced us to
each other and thanked her it was a
extremely rewarding experience for us
she actually contributed to the book to
rehash some of that it's rewarding for
everybody to express thanks it's never
too late so in an effort to encourage
you to do that I want to I want to go
through some of ours from the book again
in the book
we just had some thank-you notes that
that we gave throw back thanks to people
and but we didn't get into the story so
we can give a give a little that to whet
your palate we asked you guys to give
some throwback thanks and I'm just gonna
go with some of the light-hearted ones a
lot of you guys publicly thanked a lot
of people sincerely from the heart and I
really enjoyed reading through those and
it's powerful because you did it through
the internet that was kind of the idea
and it finds its way to those people
which is super cool
just for the sake of time and tone I'm
gonna go with some of them more like
time and tone Eve said some bloke on a
train who matrix jumped through the
closing doors to give me my gloves that
I'd left on my seat oh wow
somebody and then Eve never got to thank
him and never found out if he got
another train or if he was just stuck
there you know so then he probably isn't
still hashtag throwback thinks he's uh
you know she got her gloves well III
don't know if I would have done that I
would have thrown the gloves I would
have got into that just throwing them
and just hope that they made it to the
platform I wanted sacrifice myself
that's a good man
call Briley gave some throwback thinks
that old lady in the jeepney i don't
know what a jeepney jeepney jeepney i
think it's a vehicle that old lady in
the jeepney that heard me fart but
didn't react at all I guess she
understood me
what would the fart say don't
acknowledge what was to understand here
well the point is cause being grateful
well some things never - sometimes you
want to be acknowledged sometimes if
it's a big one
you might want to wink or you might want
a thumbs up or something you know a
smile just something to know you've done
your job
evil snail said hashtag throwback thinks
I would like to thank whoever invented
the word moist because now I can make
everyone eternally cringe yeah everybody
hates the word moist doesn't make me
cringe I'm I love it I particularly fond
of it personally
yeah moist brownie wouldn't be edible
without it without moist Caroline Qatar
ta ta army I'm so I don't know why
laughter then don't laugh at her name
Eliza the way you said it
hashtag throwback apology yeah sorry
she'd like to thank whoever looked at
chicken and thought to fry it also the
other beautiful soul who looked at fried
chicken and thought to put it in nugget
form hmm yeah that's a tough that's
tough to narrow down you probably you
they can't can't can't pinpoint the
person who first fried chicken you can
probably pinpoint the first nugget at
least you know like you know a
professional nugget I'm sure some
grandma made a nugget first nuggets just
a little piece of a chicken that fell in
the fryer man right I'm sure it was
parallel invented in many places we're
gonna get into some of ours here what do
you want to start cuz there's a lot of
these and we can't get through all of
them but anyway you want to start me I'd
really like to start with dick Bowser
okay
friend of your dad's so here's what it
says in the book dick Bowser thank you
for nearly choking on a piece of meat at
a Myrtle Beach steak house we literally
think about you every time we eat meat
and throw in a few extra cheese just for
you this is very true and we actually
back when we had our show the rhett and
Link cast live what is it 10 years ago
now could have been yeah 2007-2008 um we
would do our show on Ustream live every
week down in the basement in Lillington
and occasionally we had guests having
guests yeah my dad was a guest
we brought dick my grandparents were in
the audience every week and most of the
time pop out would fall asleep during a
live broadcast yeah and so we started
putting a camera on them and we would we
switch the camera ourselves yeah I I
would we got real high-tech by the end
of it we had like that camera switcher
mm-hmm and I'll just switch to the
camera of them not enough he's just kind
of like not enough he's sitting on the
couch but yeah we had dick bowser he had
him on because I think at the time no
relation to King Bowser no no he doesn't
he doesn't spike Super Mario Brothers
although every time he jumps up I do run
under him what is that thing that like
and hit the thing that then makes a
weird like axe yes if you hit the act
the bridge falls I mean I listen I went
to say I was a civil engineer I've got
an inch civil engineering degree I don't
and the way that that bridge were
some Mario Brothers is not sound right
or logical there's no there's no way
that that could exists first time I saw
a real drawbridge I was severely
disappointed but really that really kept
hitting that axe and nothing happened
yeah I don't it looked kind of like a
haystack to me like a little loaf of hay
really I don't know I think it's an axe
I think it's just a switch it's like a
medieval switch of some sort I really
can't picture it right now
anyway dick Bowser so dick Bowser works
with my dad he's he teaches law with my
dad and I played golf together like
every week but dick was down in Myrtle
Beach
with his wife and maybe his entire
family and eating at a steak house in
Myrtle Beach oh you weren't there no oh
you just heard about it I just tell the
story in such a compelling manner that
you assumed that I was president but
what happened was is he was having
dinner and he choked on a pieces began
to choke on a piece of steak and it was
very serious very quickly like one of
those like lodged deep no air like full
on if we don't get this out of my
trachea I will die situations and there
happened to be a man who saw him
struggling I think he was a doctor isn't
that how the story goes you don't have
to be a doctor to know how to do this
but he was qualified in some way and he
came up and he did the Heimlich on him
and he shot that piece of steak out
across the restaurant and dick Bowser at
least at the time last time we checked
in with him had not eaten steak again I
mean that is traumatizing for everybody
involved
it's like drowning in front of your
family and they're just sitting there
oh the scuba gear just watching you yeah
I I just can't imagine I can't imagine
that happens all the time I mean it's
like a really really common cause of
death to choking because there's so many
I mean you keep sending that mail down
south something's gonna end up in the
wrong destination you know what I'm
saying
odd odds are not in your favor yeah
whole trachea and esophagus coming
together thing that
that's an engineering flaw and so I
think that you he told us that story and
then we had him on the show to talk
about it I don't remember I had a lot of
human you bet we also had one of the
people who was on the plane that Sully
landed in the Hudson Mike Coleman's
burger he's a friend of a friend yeah
well I know he's a friend I might I
didn't know him but so we I know I knew
him pretty well at the time we had him
on a call like just a few weeks after it
happened yeah he was freaking standing
on the wing in that picture of all the
be the famous picture of the plane in
the Hudson he's one of the people
standing on the wing we had him on our
show and we were like this is it we're
doing it we like we got an Internet show
and we got this guy on the wing of the
plane talking to nobody cared though he
was not still on the wing no no the
loyal mythical be scared but yeah it was
such a what's the word nascent form of
entertainment it was very insular but I
will say that I actually do think and
the dick Bowser thing that didn't cause
any ripples across the internet either
but it caused a ripple in me and you
first of all you already oh yeah you
already live by this because what's your
Nana told you yeah to me this is just
like I told you so
but I have been you know I eat like a
vacuum and so it's you know I am moving
my mouth the whole time but I'm also
constantly swallowing and so if
something just reaches the back of it
it's like Hungry Hippos if something
gets in that's going down you know what
I mean that's how I eat yeah and but now
when I eat anything that has a choke
ability to it you see dicks face yeah
every time I mean me to see Diggs face
so but I tell that to my kids all the
time time to cuz it's like you know if
they're eating meat I'm like don't be a
dick Bowser yeah you boys know you be a
dick Bowser now the dick Bowser of today
yeah doesn't eat meat and
doesn't eat steak and doesn't choke chew
that meat Thank You dick browser what's
the next one that you wanted to talk
about I know you looked at these I can
tee it up tee it up for me I'll talk
about it
Garfield shaped phone oh there's a
picture of this to prove that I had the
Garfield shape phone in that picture you
can also see that I have a goofy stuffed
animal and a sailor boy teddy bear
stuffed animal and a bulletin board with
a Tony the Tiger Tail that I got from a
Frosted Flakes mail-in rebate thing and
then a license plate that says for fun
for - fun
yep that that was me the linkster for -
fun and I'm wearing a shirt that says
Palmetto on it which is not a brand I am
familiar with I think that's like a
cigarette it's like a casino or
something you are in a cigarette shirt
but I'm posing talking on my new
Garfield phone whenever you pick up the
phone now this is one of those phones
that plugs into a wall they don't
doesn't exist anymore
right when you pick up the phone
Garfield will wake up yeah he watches
you have a converse you can go in retro
stores like you can go to downtown
Pasadena and go in a store called a
retro and they'll sell these for like 70
but we found one for something we were
going around somewhere
I unapologetically put all this stuff in
my room as a kid because I was not
self-aware as a child you were you were
you were much more self-aware that's why
we make fun of how much I'm smiling and
and you don't smile you're like you have
this like cool look I'll try to be cool
trying to be cool I did not have that I
mean I had teddy bears but they were not
on display you know yeah they were in
the closet the thing keynote said
Garfield shaped phone thank you for
being the conduit for those couple of
extremely awkward conversations I had
with Leslie before she decided to dump
me for Tyler Hamilton so we gave a shout
out to Tyler Hamilton in this throw bag
thanks and when he knows mmm I know a
few years back I was having some car
trouble
back home and he was he was working at
the UM at the place if you were they
were they were they fixed the cars in
fuqua a garage no in Lillington okay in
Lillington well the funny story about
the so we obviously you know we both
dated leslie it was our first girlfriend
a lot of awkward conversation and
garfield fought i remember like i we
both dated her for about a month maybe
and it was that middle school
relationship where you when you get to
school your your boyfriend and
girlfriend and maybe you do something
like go to a dance together but then
when you try to talk on the phone at
that age it's just like with with rare
exception it's just like little boys at
age you know 12 now they just texted I
don't have to worry about it but not
commune it was like stage fright just to
speak in speaking into the torso of the
character known as Garfield doesn't help
as it turns out huh sigh oh I'm gonna
I'm gonna rip out the middle of Garfield
and talk to it didn't look like guts in
there but it still was that would've
been a nice touch that would have been a
nice touch but you've told me this story
before and I'm sure we've told it at
some point about how you were sitting
there with her in school in school while
dating her yeah and then she was writing
she was doodling and I like leaned over
and she there were hearts and stuff on
her page and there was also I saw that
it said Leslie
Tyler Peebles yeah Leslie
Tyler Peebles why and I didn't see the
Peebles I just saw Leslie Tyler no no no
no no you didn't you think I did you I
specifically remember this story you
came to me and you said she's who she
likes Tyler she's writing Leslie Tyler
people's yeah like they're like they're
married and they took her name it hurt a
lot and I said link that's her full name
Lesley Tyler Peebles was her full name
oh and you were like Oh sense of relief
but then within a week she was dating
Tyler so I was right you jerk
see I think that yeah but we were both
right yeah but what that wasn't a sign
that she was about to dump you thanks
Tyler I think she felt your insecurities
both of you this is a good one
and I actually have a story a story that
I've heard very recently related to this
Brian rat llege thank you for telling us
about fiber supplements were like
clockwork now this happened in college
Brian rat llege told us I know I don't
think I think we were I remember being
out of college okay that could that
could be true I remember being like 23
24 yeah and you know it's as happens you
you end up talking about your bowel
movement sometimes if you're here with
people that you feel close enough to and
he was like well let me tell you guys
let me tell you right now what you need
to do is you need to be taking a
spoonful of Metamucil every day you
should just do it just work it into your
routine American diet doesn't have
enough fiber it'll it'll do everything
it'll regulate both ways no matter which
way you you swing it'll get you right
back to normal
mm-hm and so okay and we both did it and
we he was very serious about it this was
not a joking conversation it wasn't even
hey isn't it funny that we're talking
about this yeah yeah he was so centered
it's serious business that we gave us
pause yeah and then I mean there's a
reason why there's a whole half an hour
aisle and like every drugstore dedicated
to this stuff and so now both of us use
this on a regular basis especially when
traveling it is the perfect solution to
you know what happens when you travel
sometimes and your body is like nope
hold everything in because I'm traveling
like I don't know where you're at don't
know where you're going and the next
thing you know you've gone three days
without taking a dump yeah this
completely solves that problem which is
amazing that your body can do that you
know it's like how's my body know that
I'm traveling well you know how do I
know that you know his middle name is
Tyler my theory is a mysterious world
you know my theory about that adaptation
is that when back in the day
three days you're going into enemy
territory and so you're nervous you're
in a new place and you don't want to
take a dump because that's two strikes
against you the first strike is you got
to stop and take a dump that's the best
time to kill a man yeah oh and he's
taking a dump number two
squat and knock him off you're gonna
leave your you're leaving yourself
you're leaving a clue evidence so like
that's not our our people's poop that's
somebody else's poop look at that Barry
I don't recognize that Barry so there's
a survival adaptation to hold in your
poop for a few days but when you go to
summer camp or you just go on vacation
or you you know you're just traveling
around you don't want to hold your poop
it's the hunter-gatherers it's a
vestigial adaptation but certainly Brian
Ratliff ound out that he was think tin
the book because really jesse was like
oh somebody tagged Brian rat llege in a
post about your book and said hey here
and I took the picture of this page and
I said you're in the book of mythicality
and he was like thanks for letting me
know I had no idea so he actually found
out that he was the recipient of
throwback things I wonder if he went out
and bought one went out and bought a
book yeah that's a ring of Metamucil
both that's why we put his name in there
was this set at least we'll sell one to
Brian in another one you may be thinking
you should give one to Brian or you may
be thinking you should have told Brian
that you put this about him in the book
and to both of those I say well too late
you're probably right but we don't have
that kind of time chewing tobacco
another substance that we've
experimented with okay say that one
thank you for having such sobering
warnings printed on your packaging as
well as for tasting absolutely awful you
made us a vomit as 16 year olds and then
vowed to never try you again you may
strike you as odd that two guys that you
think seem relatively normal would have
really gone in hard on some chewing
tobacco but you got to understand a how
old we are and be where we're from and
see this way that Hank Williams jr. had
over our lives at that time
I don't want a dog North Carolina you
know that much but you can do it and
then I'll defend this a little bit well
so it was customary for the boys of our
age at our high school to experiment
with smokeless tobacco in fact the first
time that I ever well if you looked out
at any window of our high school you
would see a tobacco field true so it was
just it was looming but I mean I was on
probably what is the most preppie you
know like you're thinking this is the
least redneck situation you could be in
I'm on the golf team right mm-hmm but it
was on the golf team that Island a yacht
rock that I was introduced to dip which
is the you know the tune tobacco that
you take and you put in your lip mmm
of course it gives you mouth cancer and
it's horrible for you but we were young
we didn't know we didn't care and also
the whole golf team we put this stuff in
your lip and then of course you do it
because you want to be cool and you and
and then you start doing it because it's
it tastes so bad but you're doing it
because you want to be cool and it gives
you this it does give this little effect
you know you get you get this mild
effect but what I think you have this a
similar story but what I did is I
remembered it gives me I get sick
thinking about it I was at home alone
and my parents were going somewhere for
the day and I had like a whole day in
the house and I was like I'm gonna get
myself a tin of cherry skull and I just
set up there in my in the upstairs room
watching TV and I just sat there with
there's just a dip just sitting sitting
there I wasn't hanging out with it
wasn't experiencing it with anybody I'm
just sitting there with his cherry
flavored tobacco just stinging my bottom
lip as I watch TV and then like an hour
and a half later I stand up and
immediately it's just like I'm super
lightheaded I run to the bathroom and
just vomit how did you get it because
it's hilly
I mean I can tell the story of how we
got the chewing tobacco did you just buy
it you just go to the place in
Lillington that doesn't ask your age
well that is the story and Hank Williams
Hank Williams jr. had a song cuz the boy
can't survive
yeah and he was he was he's who was he
so angry at he says I had a good friend
in New York City he never called me by
my name just hillbilly but he was killed
by a man with a switchblade knife for
$43 my friend lost his life and then
it's Dennis like wow like just finished
him Beach nothing that dude's eyes and
shoot him with my old 45 cause a country
boy can survive country folks can
survive so yeah so it's about shooting
somebody he'd liked it well he wanted to
spit Beechnut in his eye
now Beechnut is a particular brand of
chewing tobacco and then after in his
eye then you shoot him shooting with a
45 because I rhymes with 45 now when you
got to blind him first yeah I'm sure he
would never actually do that he was he
was doing what an artist did like
notorious b.i.g was playing a character
if you would ask like he said I'd love
to we didn't say I would do I love to
shoot that guy yeah I'm not going to and
I didn't write not admitting anything of
course we're listening to that well
we're well yeah and we latched on to the
Beechnut part of it we don't latch on to
the 45 part no no happy to get a gun
absolutely not
but what we did do was we went to the
corner store I didn't go to the I didn't
get in Lillington I'm one of the dip
around around right before you go to
wombling signs around the corner from
Nana and Papa's house yeah went did that
one because I knew that none of my
relatives went to that one now the the
see mark just a few blocks away is the
one that all of my relatives went to and
they they knew all the cashiers and
everything but the it wasn't called a
junior mark whatever it was called we
went there because I was like listen
we'll go in there
we'll get us some chewing tobacco and
then we'll we'll get we'll get out and
they won't recognize me right and of
course we get in there and I'm like what
you kind of we gonna get what kind we
didn't discuss it ahead of time I was
just like we'll take the Beechnut
wondering how many Beechnut packs were
sold because of that song hmm um yeah I
see could have said red man but he
didn't you open up the pouch and it you
just get hit by this strong scent of
tobacco with like I wouldn't say it has
a chemical overtone to it but it's in
like in writings about in the same in
the same we have a physical reaction
like if you were to open like a strong
bottle of cleaner and it would be like
oh and it just like knocks you back a
little bit that's how pungent opening a
pouch of chewing tobacco is or do I
can't dip right and it takes a lot of
gumption to like pull out a plug of that
and then shove it in your cheat you
shove in your chicken you slowly chew it
and you spit my it's one of the nastier
habits that there is my dad did not chew
tobacco for much of his life but I do
remember when I would visit him on the
weekends as a very very young child and
he was farming tobacco he would chew
tobacco so I had this subconscious
thought that was planted that like my
dad who I just thought was just awesome
I also thought that chewing tobacco was
awesome for that reason yeah I mean I
did so I felt like it was some sort of
rite of passage at that point as like a
16 year old well and there is there is
something about and that's what gave me
the gumption to get out and it's like
we're gonna do this well there's
something about redoing something that's
a little bit outside of the lines that
you know you should be walking in that's
not super know at least on the short
term it's not like it's not like we were
shooting up heroin you know is it's it's
it's a it's a pretty low risk thing if
you're gonna do it a couple of times the
problem is the risk is getting addicted
to it the next
you know you got mouth cancer just just
go just do a google search of chewing
tobacco mouth cancer that's all you need
to know that you should never try this
but we would sit out there at the river
and do it and just basically just make
each other sick and says are you sick
enough yet I'm sick now man let's quit
you know that was pretty much what we
did it's so it's so gross can't say it's
I miss it now but speaking it's not it's
so weird it's not like even in the
short-term
it's a great experience but then you get
mouth cancer no it's a horrible
experience at a stand just become
addicted to the to the they could become
addicted to the to the effects of it
that's a big speed bump to drive over to
get to your destination well think about
the first time if you if you if you just
smoked a cigarette how would you think
that this that it's a fun thing or a
good idea but then next thing you know
you're addicted to it that's true okay I
guess here's one and we're gonna pull
out the paper that we have here oh yeah
we want to thank the done Daily Record
thank you for featuring us on your June
26 2009 cover alongside her when woman
murdered teen charged in Sampson horse
farm in trouble again so this is
something that we had framed way back in
the day and we keep it up in our office
because it is very grounding in a lot of
ways because it is a about as clear of a
picture of where we come from as you
could possibly have this is and we're at
June 26th 27th 28th of 2009 innocent
they did a feature article so this is
like the daily paper that we got growing
up not the city paper from the called
the the News & Observer which came from
Raleigh this is the one that came from
done it was like the Harnett County
paper that you got every day in a little
mailbox that everybody had connected to
their mailbox that said daily records
yes they do so they were to come in
there put it in but they didn't throw it
I remember in movies I would see people
throwing the paper in the drive when I
realized anyhow we do it around here you
put it in the Daily Record but mailbox
that everybody had at the street so but
we're featured in the middle right in
the middle and it says enter the world
of internet Ament and it's all
containers in turn attainers and it's
about what we were doing at the time but
really ironically now what it means is
if you were to enter the world of us at
as Internet Tanner's back then that
world would be everything that surrounds
us in the other headlines which are herb
urban woman murdered
Irwin was the close bike town teen
charged and of course Sampson horse farm
in trouble again which is the other one
that we we mentioned but let me we're
not gonna stop there because how many
times does a horse farm got to be in
trouble to make the front page twice as
one too many and how is a horse how is
the horse farm in trouble well I think
maybe they're doing something bad with
the horses or maybe they don't have
enough horses animal neglect that's what
it was has been investigated again for
the same alleged offense Benson to
celebrate eighty nine years of southern
gospel mmm there so like just that
sentence alone you don't have I don't
think you can appreciate just how many
just how rich that statement is Vincent
alone let me just see me before that
Benson Benson knows how to celebrate
because Benson is the place where every
year they would have something called
mule days where people would drive from
from from miles miles and show up with
their mules and then pareo a parade do a
parade did African mule and they
canceled mule days oh I just got it got
to crazy man too many mules and the
other thing was we used to there was
something that the high schoolers used
to do called cruise Benson yes and you
would drive to Benson which was like 20
miles away and you would ride around
with your windows rolled down and music
playing yes cruising and then they made
it illegal but when we right when we got
our license so like we're talking like
94 they made cruising a leak I was so
looking forward to like man I can't wait
a cruise Benson and they freaking made
it illegal and then they got rid of mule
days Benson what's up man
then down here we've got another thing
from Irwin Irwin woman wins another
preliminary she's a beauty pageant
she's got a bathing suit on on the on
the front of this thing she won Miss
Fayetteville good work and then former
Linden man charged with lewd acts on a
child oh good gracious no we're not
making light of any of this stuff we're
no we're not trying to give you it's us
you got to understand how typical every
single article on this is it's so
indicative of where we come from okay
when you say you think Harnett County
can you read that read the cat read the
caption on our picture cuz we got a big
picture and there's a lot of wonderful
there's a lot of wonderful things about
Harnett County but there's also a lot of
just the things that are typical of just
a rural place you know where a lot of
people just get trapped you got women
getting murdered by teens you got
southern gospel going on for 89 years
you got horse farms that are in trouble
you got young ladies winning beauty
pageants and you got people performing
lewd acts on children oh I'm just saying
I'm not I'm not making light of any of
it I'm just saying that that's where we
come from and then write in them and we
that's why we have this thing yeah
framed right in the middle here we are
this is don't ever forget this don't
ever forget this is who we are man this
is where we come from and what does the
caption say link Neal left and Rhett
mcLaughlin practice one of the many
songs that have made them a hit on the
internet on YouTube
and on their website
rhettandlink.com/store is in Lillington
and some of their work features the town
as a backdrop that's true that's true
that's true a lot of it did need to go
back and help those horses yeah okay
let's just pause for a moment and be
thankful with silent
I think that's it
I think I feel great you don't want to
thank anybody else well did you want to
think I just first I had one more that I
thought kind of fits yeah do it the
theme that we're in right now is
thinking the pharmacist to Elliott's in
downtown Fuquay thanks for taking a
break filling prescriptions to hold the
mic from our epic rap battle video
behind your store did we miss Bell mic
okay in my seam no the reason again this
is this is what editors do we had an
argument not an argument but so after we
wrote the book we you know we had an
editor but then we had like a
professional event picker yeah somebody
who goes another layer deeper to think
about your grammar and punctuation and
everything and they and they basically
go through and correct and then they get
to certain places where it's not just a
simple punctuation or spelling
correction but it's just a decision that
has to be made and then they run it by
you so we've always said Mike as m.i.c
cuz it's short for microphone but they
said technically when you're saying Mike
the short for microphone you should
spell it in my ke technically that's
what was correct and that's why it says
that in this particular think you know
well link is short for Lincoln but it's
with a K so I'm not gonna argue with any
of that back to the point though
yeah the pharmacists as important of a
job as that is he was still just able to
mosey out there and be our boom operator
with no particular time constraint it
was great
that's a that doesn't happen anymore but
that that well it would be a long
commute for him but I but again it was
there was something special about being
in a place where no one else was we
didn't know anybody else who was making
YouTube videos at the time did not that
same time but we told this story before
when we were doing commercial Kings how
we shot the intro to our show on IFC we
shot it in the middle of Main Street in
the and the cop stopped yeah literally
the Trop i was in the middle of the
street and he like rolls down his window
and he's like y'all mean y'all need any
help
and then another guy rolls down his
window and says I'm the town
commissioner
and anytime y'all need anything just let
me know it's like well you know what
they did they both saw the done Daily
Record exactly we're right on the front
of it so there you go that's like it
could carry that thing around as a
credential back in a day but I you know
I think the point is it's it's fun to
reminisce but it's powerful when you can
transition a reminisce ation into being
grateful and it's never too late to
think somebody you know what Brian rat
llege I wonder how he felt knowing that
we put his complete name in our book and
associated it with Metamucil
I hope he's honored I think he probably
feels great if you still got the routine
going yeah I'm bet he's he's doing
fabulous man he just keeps it moving
it's like a train I just want to
encourage you mythical beasts to be your
mythical best buy throw back thanking
someone in your life used a hashtag if
you want to TBT or throw back things I
think you should use the hashtag and
then I think because it can be done
these days I think you should tag that
person that you're thinking if they're
still around to be tagged because that
you know it can be very different let's
like we talked about in the book it can
be very difficult to thank somebody in
person especially when people are like
there's like a moment in time that you
have to be thankful like to live like
actually come out and say it yeah that
you're thankful and usually if you don't
say it at that moment the chance that
you get the first time you never say it
right because there's a lot to overcome
but there's a lower threshold to
thinking somebody through the internet
and I don't think it means any less
necessarily and usually it will lead to
some kind of interaction that might
actually lead to a conversation person
that you can have with somebody so take
that for what it's worth and it's worth
a lot
I would like to that's for them to say
let us know using hashtag ear biscuits
let us know what you think about this
convo and we appreciate you hanging out
with us this week you know will speak at
you again next week have a great
Thanksgiving yes do it
[Music]